So, da bin ich etwas für mich unorthodox zur Uhrzeit.
Nicht vormittags, nicht abends. So, fast schon Abend, aber nicht ganz Abend.
Was steht an? Wir machen heute die letzten drei Z-Server glücklich.
Also, wieder extreme White-Pepo-Happy-Time.
Aber erst mal ein bisschen resizen hier, dass das alles auf den Bildschirm passt.
Ja, lasst euch durch den Titel nicht verwirren. Mir ist, ich dachte, die Leute sind heute alle
furchtbar lustig. Da bin ich auch lustig.
Heute ist der Tag der lustigen, ganz furchtbar witzigen Leute.
Ich glaube, ich muss ein Emote hinzufügen, nur für heute. Das kann ich danach wieder löschen.
Was haltet ihr hier von? Warum hat es keine Animation?
Normalerweise sollte es eine Animation sein. Ich habe gedacht, das passt für heute ganz gut.
Nope, anscheinend nicht. Moment, Moment.
Vielleicht so als GIF? Geht das GIF jetzt? Mal checken.
Das hat einen Hintergrund, Mann. Ist wieder hochgradig kompliziert.
Ist wieder hochgradig transparenten GIF zu finden. Aber gut, ich meine, für heute wird
es reichen. Für heute reicht es auch mit kaputtem Hintergrund.
Moin. Kein Ton, Lul. Ja, glaube ich dir sofort.
Ja, passt das Jahr dazu. Kein Ton. Leute, das nächste Mal, wenn die Leute lustig
sind, ist dann am 1. April. Restliches Jahr über alles Zetke. Heute mega funny.
Ich finde die meisten Faschingsveranstaltungen so ultra cringe. Ich mochte das noch nie.
Also auch als ich kleiner war nicht. Konnte damit nie was anfangen. Ich meine, es ist
ja schön, wenn die Leute Spaß dran haben, sollen sie machen. Aber ich konnte damit nie
irgendwas anfangen. Die Musiklautstärke ist wieder total inkonsistent.
Meistens cringe, ja. Sollte kurz ins Discord gucken, was man versucht
zu erreichen. Okay. Mir hat jemand auf Twitter eben ein Link geschickt zu einer Stellenanzeige.
Mit dem Hinweis kann ich doch im nächsten Stellenanzeigen Video benutzen. Aber ich
zeige es euch mal. Das ist auch schon wieder. Eigentlich finde ich die Stellenanzeigen ganz
cool, aber was sie wieder haben wollen ist halt total bescheuert. Okay, die Playlist
zackt richtig. Die ist mal laut und mal leise. Es fällt mir jedes Mal auf, dass die Playlist
zackt. Trotzdem mache ich die immer wieder an. Na gut, ich mach mal kurz auf. Ich meine,
hier sollten bei euch schon alle Alarmglocken läuten, oder? Wenn ihr das seht. Admin Rockstar.
Da weißt du schon Bescheid, oder? Auf gehts. Jaja, alles ablehnen. Leute, ich muss euch
leider Flashbangen, sonst funktioniert die Seite nicht richtig. Sit Computers. Du liebst
Heavy Metal und behandelst Server wie deine Git-App. Schon ein bisschen Minimal-Cringe,
aber okay. Ich habe nicht vor, dass ich aufhöre. Ich mache YouTube Zeug seit zwölf Jahren,
zwölf Jahren oder so. Damit dürfte ich wahrscheinlich eines der am längsten aktiven deutschen YouTube-Leute
sein, oder? Wer macht den Scheiß schon zwölf Jahre? Also am Stück. Ohne längere Pausen.
Ich meine, ich habe auch mal Phasen gehabt, da habe ich nicht viel gemacht, aber so lange
Pausen habe ich ja nie gehabt. Wenn ich das schon lese, man. An sich spricht mich das
irgendwie an. Ja, ich mag Heavy Metal, ich mag auch Git. Ob ich eher Admin Rockstar werden
will, habe ich so meine Zweifel. Gucken wir mal schnell, was die haben wollen. Wir bieten
dir nichts geringeres als deinen Traumjob und Heavy Metal bei der Arbeit. Okay. Ob das
mein Traumjob ist, das könnt ihr ja gar nicht so weit beurteilen. Das müsste ich ja entscheiden.
Gucken wir mal, ob das, ob das, ob da was dran ist, dass das mein Traumjob sein könnte.
Steige jetzt ein als Systemadministrator. Männlich weiß deutsch, wie immer. Wird gepointet
da drauf. Okay, okay. Sit Computer ist ein junges, aufstrebendes Unternehmen. Unser neu
gegründetes Rechenzentrum, der neue Coworking Space. Was ist ein Coworking Space? Das ist
doch so, das ist doch so was in der Richtung, so dass die Fläche geschert ist, quasi mit
das unterschiedliche Unternehmen sich quasi diese Fläche teilen, oder? Ist das ein Coworking
Space? Also wenn du keine eigenen, wenn du keine eigenen Büros hast, sondern die irgendwo
was mietest. Du hast heute ein Paket bekommen, ja, wann hast du es denn bestellt, wenn es
jetzt erst ankommt? Wenn du das damals hastest vor einem Jahr bestellt, oder wie? Und das
eigene Videostudio bieten ungeahnte Möglichkeiten für unsere Kunden und für dich. Bei uns kannst
du kreativ sein, dich einbringen und bekommst die Chance, dich weiterzuentwickeln. Ja, okay.
Wanna be an admin Rockstar. Finde in vier kurzen Fragen heraus, ob du zu uns passt.
Was ist denn, wenn ich sag eher nicht? Wenn ich sage eher nicht oder ja, los geht's, passiert
das gleiche. Exakt der gleiche Link. Interessiert dich schon mal nicht, wie es aussieht. Krasser
Klick Effekt, oder? Dies übrigens mein Overwatch Team, also mein Overwatch Team. Also Hover
und Klick Effekt. Okay, also guck mal mal. Wie viele Jahre Erfahrung hast du schon als
Systemadministrator gesammelt? Über fünf. Hast du bereits erfahr... Leider ja. Hast
du Erfahrung mit Virtualisierung? Ja. Hast du bereits Erfahrung? Hast du bereits Führungserfahrung?
Nein, und ich will auch nicht. Was ist dir bei deinem Job am wichtigsten? Karriere machen,
viel Neues lernen, ein sicherer Job, noch keine Ahnung. Wie wär's mit Geld verdienen?
Geld verdienen und nicht täglicher Abfuck. Das würde mich persönlich, würde das wahrscheinlich
schon ausreichen. Ob der Job wahnsinnig sicher ist, juckt mich nicht. Ob ich viel Neues lerne,
juckt mich auch nicht, weil das ist zwangsläufig der Fall. Außer man muss Kobalt programmieren.
Karriere machen interessiert mich auch nicht, solange ich ordentlich Kohle verdiene. Also
ist eigentlich nix. Okay, dann machen wir Geldscheine. Okay. Passt geschafft. Letzter
Schritt. Okay. Was passiert dann, wenn ich sage, keine Ahnung? Okay, wenn man nicht weiß,
was man will, dann erfüllt man die Kriterien nicht. Dann haben sie einen Link auf Instagram,
den es noch nicht gibt. Nice. Ach, die gibt's doch. Okay, haben die vielleicht auch noch
was? Okay, was suchen die dann sonst noch? Deine Aufgabe. Okay, jetzt geht's los. Richtig
schön Emoji Fight. Also ohne Mist, ich find's gar nicht schlecht bis hierhin. Also ich meine,
ich hab einen neuen Job, ich werd mich da sicherlich nicht bewerben oder so. Heavy Metal,
ich mag Heavy Metal. Und Admin Sachen liegen mir auch, also warum nicht? Also was wollen
sie denn haben? Deine Aufgaben. Du baust ein Support Team auf. Moment, ihr sucht einen
Admin und kein Teamleiter. Das geht schon gut los. Passt ja heute dazu wieder. Heute sind
alle lustig, vielleicht ist die Stellenanzeige nur für heute und den ersten April. Okay,
du baust ein Support Team auf und entwickelst es stetig weiter. Jawoll, ich bin Admin, ich
bin kein Teamleiter, man. Ich will auch kein Teamleiter sein. Du findest Lösungen. Okay,
Leute, es ist gelaufen. Da bist du ja. Ich hab gedacht, ich mach's schon mal auf. Du findest
das First-Level-Support und Endkundensupport. Oh je, hör mal auf. Moment, das sind ja zwei
Sachen, die ich absolut im Leben nicht machen würde. Leute, Teamleiter und First-Level-Support.
Das ist ja. Das ist ja bei der Kombination. Die Kombination ist ja schon per Definition
komplette Abfall. Strategie und Weiterentwicklung. Du hast gute Ideen bei uns. Darfst du sie
umsetzen, verbessern und weiterentwickeln? Ja, das sag' dir jetzt. Du entwickelst MSP-Lösungen.
Bin ich der Einzige, der keine Ahnung hat, was MSP bedeutet? Microsoft Powerpoint-Lösung?
Was ist MSP? Movie Star Planet. Ich glaube eher nicht. MSP? Microsoft? Azure Managed
Services Provider. Du entwickelst Managed Services Provider-Lösung? Das ergibt zumindest
ein bisschen Sinn. Das ergibt zumindest ein bisschen Sinn, wenn man das damit übersetzt.
Wobei ich ja persönlich Movie Star Planet besser finde dafür. Du setzt Maßstäbe.
Aber ich nehme die auch ins Video rein. Ich muss dir nämlich sagen, Enrixl, ich finde
die Aufmachung und das alles Drumherum, finde ich persönlich relativ gut gemacht. Also auch
das mit Heavy Metal und so, würde mich durchaus ansprechen. Das einzig Blöde ist, das hier
ergibt wenig Sinn und die Kombination aus First-Level und Teamleiter, ich meine, was
haben die sich denn da wieder gedacht bei? Außerdem geht es wohl hauptsächlich um Windows-Administration,
wenn ich das jetzt mal so, ich interpretiere das jetzt mal einfach rein, weil ein bisschen
Aufgaben wären tatsächlich nicht verkehrt. Ich meine, die Aufgaben sind mega abstrakt,
da hast du keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich auf dich zukommt. Du definierst für dich
und dein Team. Alter, ich bin kein Teamleiter, ich bin Systemadministrator. Was erzählt ihr
denn alles hier von die ganze Zeit? Du definierst für dich und dein Team regelmäßig neue Ziele
und sorgst dafür, dass sie auch erreicht werden. Das widerspricht sich insofern, wenn ich regelmäßig
neue Ziele definiere, so nachdem auch so schneller als ich die alten erreicht habe, dann werde
ich nie fertig. Aber egal, aber ich bin Admin, ich bin kein Teamleiter. Eure waren nicht schlecht,
sie waren insofern so gut, dass ich mich noch sogar dunkel dran erinnern kann. Du hast Erfahrung
im Aufbau und der Führung eines IT-Teams, dann schließe dich jetzt in Leitender Funktion
einem modernen Unternehmen, an welchem du deine Ideen einbringen kannst. Ja, aber ich bin Admin,
ich bin kein Teamleiter. Es kam heute eine Bewerbung, vielleicht hat sogar jemand aus
dem Stream, man weiß ja nicht. Achso, das ist ein Template, aber das Template finde ich
auch nicht. Also ich finde es durchaus okay. Also ich finde die Anzeige an sich ist ansprechend
gemacht, was drin steht. Und was heißt, doch, ergibt irgendwo schon Sinn, auch wenn die
Stellenanzeige, also der Titel und das Teamleiter wollen nicht zusammenpassen. Aber das hier
halt, an der First Level Support plus Teamleitung, das ist ja ganz schlimm. Was wir bieten, okay,
doppelt Rakete. Guck mal hier, einmal Rakete, nochmal Rakete. Flache Hierarchien, mitbestimmen
statt abzunehmen, wird bei uns täglich gelebt. Ja Moment, das sagt dir, ob das wirklich so
ist. Da habe ich meine Zweifel, bis ich es sehe. Familiäres Arbeitsumfeld. Das kannst
du auch mal ohne Probleme, weil es ist ja nicht für die Familie, kannst du auch mal 10 Stunden
die Woche länger schaffen. Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten. Alter, bla bla bla, kurze Entscheidungswege.
Gestaltungsspielraum. Alle Fragen geklärt. Nein, die hauptsächliche Frage, was mache
ich denn eigentlich oder was wollt ihr eigentlich, geht überhaupt nicht aus der Anzeige hervor.
Macht ihr Linux, macht ihr Windows, macht ihr VMWare, macht ihr Azure Cloud, macht ihr
Google, macht ihr AWS, was macht ihr denn? Schon wieder, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Okay, Template und Idee finde ich ganz gut, Umsetzung mangelhaft. MSP, wie gesagt, ich
habe keine Ahnung was MSP ist. Wahrscheinlich Managed Service Provider. Wahrscheinlich,
man weiß es nicht genau. Eine Frage zu VMWare, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es um Ordner zwischen
einem Windows? Hast du das nicht schon mal gefragt vor einer Woche? Oder war das jemand
anderes? Die Frage kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor. Ich lese gleich, ich lese gleich weiter
vor. Eine Frage zu VMWare, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es, übrigens wir machen heute die letzten
verbliebenen SETGE Servers. Ich sage es nur, falls jetzt die Leute fragen, was gibt es
heute. Ich switche gleich wieder rüber, ich mache nur mal schnell ein Update in der Zwischenzeit
hier. Ich mache nur mal kurz ein Update, dass es durch ist, bis wir dann anfangen. Was?
Wahrscheinlich, weil oben packt man gerade läuft. Ich habe zum falschen Zeitpunkt Enter
gedrückt. War die letzte Mal nicht da, was ist? Erzähle ich gleich. Ich zeige es gleich
nochmal für alle, die nicht dabei waren. Das schöne ist, dass die Aufgaben untereinander
abgeschlossen sind und es macht nichts, wenn man die letzten Folgen verpasst hat. Ich zeige
es gleich. Welche Möglichkeiten gibt es, um Ordner zwischen einem Windows Host System
und einem Windows Gast zu teilen? Der Standard Shared Folder Feature funktioniert für mich
nicht, da ich hier immer wieder auf Swim Link Fehler stoße. Hast du eine Idee? Die einfachste
Variante wäre tatsächlich Windows Share. Wenn das mit den Shared Folders nicht funktioniert,
du kannst den Windows Share entweder in der VM machen oder eben auch auf deinem Host machen.
Du klickst den Ordner einfach rechts an und sagst, du kennst das ja wahrscheinlich, du
klickst den Ordner rechts an, gehst auf Properties, Sharing und gibst das Ding frei und dann machst
du Mount CIFS und hängst dir das in der VM ein. Das kannst du machen. Theoretisch brauchst
du noch nicht mal Route-Rechte dafür. Je nachdem, mit was man das macht. Also wahrscheinlich
ist die, oder du hast Nass und taust die Daten da drüber aus. Du kannst übrigens auch Track
und Drop machen, das funktioniert meistens ganz gut, aber das ist natürlich für öftere
Transfers und Sachen, die du mit beiden Betriebssystemen bearbeiten willst, nicht so sinnvoll. Also
du kannst auch Track und Drop machen. Du kannst zum Beispiel, da mache ich hier gerade Updates,
du kannst hier zum Beispiel auch ohne Probleme, sag mal hier, du startest das und du willst
jetzt CONT.TXT, was auch immer das jetzt gibt. CONT.TXT. Emoji overlapen geht nicht, resizing
können oder Bildschirme? Ach, das kann man alles wegschmeißen, das ist doch schon uralt.
Was ist stream.txt? Ach, was wir heute machen wollen. Ok, jetzt können wir alles löschen,
das ist uralt. Guck mal, ich hab da sogar ein Sammler-Verzeichnis, da kann man es rein
mounten. Aber du kannst ohne Probleme, wenn es sich um einzelne Dateien handelt, na super,
geil, sehr schön. Ich kann keine GUI-Anwendung unter Liebungsbedienung, das funktioniert
einfach nicht. Du kannst hier rüber Track und Dropen, guck. Funktioniert, du kannst
hier Documents, wupp, wupp, wupp. Funktioniert, kannst du rüber Track und Dropen. Umgedreht
geht das übrigens auch, ja. Manchmal. Manchmal geht das. Ne, meistens gehts, meistens gehts,
was er jetzt verschmeißt. Aber wahrscheinlich, weil es die Datei schon gegeben hat, hat er
jetzt irgendein Problem. Ja, das geht, aber das ist natürlich für öfteren Datei-Austausch
nichts. Ja, ich würde einen Windows-Share machen. Du kannst den Windows-Share natürlich
auch, also je nachdem, was du für eine Desktop-Interface hast, es gibt auch viele Desktop-Interfaces,
die tatsächlich Windows-Shares direkt übers GUI zu konfigurieren erlauben. Wobei man das
nicht braucht. Oder hier eben das Einhängen auch über hier Network. Da brauchst du die
passenden Tuna-Plugins für, dann kannst du sogar hier drüber machen. Tuna-Samba, ich
weiß gar nicht wie das heißt. Was? Ne. Ja, gibt es auch Plugins für. Also ich würde
es tatsächlich im Windows-Share machen. Ich würde den Ordner in Windows freigeben, einhängen
und gut ist. Du musst den nicht auf Plitsch umstellen. Du kannst auch mit Nat auf dein
Windows-House zugreifen, ist gar kein Problem. Ja, gucken wir uns gleich an. Kurze Frage,
gute Server-Anbieter, die ihr empfehlen könnt. Hetzner, sage ich jetzt erstens aus dem Grund,
weil die mich manchmal sponsoren. Leider ist mein Ref-Link mit 20€ Startguthaben kaputt.
Gebated? Es ist aber auch ein bisschen davon abhängig, was du machen willst. Erzähl doch
mal, was du machen willst. Was hast du vor? Es gibt schon unterschiedliche Stärken und
Schwächen der Server-Anbieter bzw. auch der Service-Anbieter. Ne, das geht in Vmw nicht,
das ist kaputt. Kannste knicken. Ich habe auch auf GitHub geguckt und die haben auch keinen
Bock das lauffähig zu machen. Die sagen, du sollst GPU-Pass-Through verwenden, wenn
man es benutzen will. Habe ich halt schon wieder keinen Bock drauf. Ist aber leider wie der
meiste Wayland-Shit. Die juckt das nicht, ob der Kram läuft oder nicht. Die denken, mein
Projekt ist nicht das Problem, alle anderen sind das Problem, die es benutzen wollen.
Die anderen sollen erstmal ihren Kram richtig machen, mein Projekt ist perfekt. Das habe
ich schon in vielen Wayland-Sachen gesehen, deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich auch absehbare
Zeit auch weiterhin i3 mit off of x Basis verwenden und nicht Wayland. Also ich wollte
einen Server overall haben, weil ich jetzt keinen Server zu Hause haben wollte, also
wirklich overall spielen. Naja, Moment, Moment, das würde ich mir überlegen. Wenn du private
Sachen da drauf betreiben willst, die würde ich nicht ins Internet hängen, dann würde
ich mir tatsächlich lieber was daheim hinstellen. Wenn du natürlich nur üben willst, wenn
du das rein zum Basteln haben willst, dann kannst du dir irgendeine VM bei jedem x beliebigen
Haus da holen. Aber wenn du Nextcloud haben willst, Fileshares, NAS Geschichten, wobei
NAS ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn in der Cloud, Backups und sowas, das würde ich mir zweimal
überlegen, ob ich das alles in der Cloud stehen habe. Ich meine, der Kram ist standardmäßig,
zumindest IP-technisch von jedem auf der Welt über das Internet erreichbar, weil da laufen
vielleicht keine Services dafür, aber IP-technisch Server von überall, das würde ich nicht machen.
Also ich würde nicht meine privaten Sachen irgendwie auf einem Cloud-Server hosten. Ansonsten,
wenn du einfach nur irgendwas brauchst, um zu basteln, dann ist die nächste Frage und
es reicht dann eigentlich auch schon, wo man sich Gedanken haben muss, ist die nächste
Frage, willst du den permanent haben oder willst du den immer nur wieder zum Basteln
haben? Wenn du immer mal nur wieder ab und zu was zum Basteln haben willst, dann kannst
du Hetzner Cloud oder irgendeinen anderen Anbieter nehmen, dort eine VM erstellen, basteln
und die VM danach wieder löschen, weil dann bezahlst du schlicht und ergreifend Minuten
bis Stundenweise und es kostet so gut wie nichts. Wenn du da ein paar Stunden im Monat bastelst,
bewegst du dich im Euro, wenn überhaupt im Centbereich wahrscheinlich sogar noch. Wenn
du das immer laufen lassen willst, also 24-7 und wenn du auch ein bisschen Leistung haben
willst, dann sind die Hetzner Server Auktionen gar nicht so übel. Da kannst du zum Beispiel
gucken, was haben sie hier, Preis, ok für 0 Euro gibt es keinen Server, wer hätte das
gedacht, ok, das billigste ist 40 Euro, ok dann ist das aktuell gar nicht mal so günstig,
dann ist das gar nicht mal so günstig, mit 40 Euro, da bist du mit dem Hetzner Cloud
preisen für was kleines eigentlich schon besser. Ich persönlich finde die hier am
besten, Preis-Leistungstechnisch, billigsten ist natürlich die hier, die Kiste hier, du
kannst übrigens, wenn du keine Public IP haben willst, keine Public IP 4.4 haben willst,
kriegst du sogar nochmal 50 Cent billiger. Brauchst du ja nicht, also brauchst du ja
nicht zwangsläufig, je nachdem was du machen willst, brauchst du ja nicht zwangsläufig
die Public IP. So, der 20 GB Traffic das täuscht, weil Traffic ist bei Hetzner Unlimited in
eine Richtung und die andere Richtung ist 20 TB, ich glaube bei Hetzner ist das so,
ausgehender Traffic kostet oder, ich weiß es nicht, wie rum, bei Hetzner ist die eine
Sache Unlimited und die andere, aber das reicht dicke, das reicht dicke, erstmal ohne Probleme.
Ja, Hetzner hat ordentlich zugelegt, wobei gerade bei den Server Auktionen es wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen daran liegt, dass die Leute die Server halt nicht so weit runter fallen
lassen und direkt schon kaufen. Also ich persönlich finde das Preis-Leistungstechnisch das hier
die beste Kiste ist. Es sei denn ihr braucht RAM und Speicher, dann kann durchaus sowas
ja auch attraktiv sein, aber ich finde Preis-Leistungstechnisch ist das die beste Kiste, die sie haben.
9€ im Monat oder 8,39€ im Monat, weil man keine Public IPv4 Adresse haben will, 8,40€
im Monat, 4 GB und 3 CPU Kerne. Also das ist richtig gut Performance, 3 CPU Kerne reichen
für nahezu alles was man machen will, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie eine fette
Seite betreibt, also auch regelmäßiges Background Processing von allem und das Service läuft
immer schnell, 3 CPU Kerne ist top, 4 GB RAM reicht in der Regel auch, ansonsten muss man
halt hochgehen, die hier macht finde ich jetzt, ja je nachdem was man machen will, macht alles
hin. Also ich finde Headset trotzdem nicht übel, auch wenn es jetzt ein bisschen teurer
geworden ist, die hier kenne ich zum Beispiel gar nicht, Notes oder ist es Noeasy, von denen
habe ich noch nie was gehört, Noeasy, ok zeig mal her, ok wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an,
wir müssen ja nicht hier gleich die Hardcore Linux Sache starten, wir können uns ein paar
Sachen angucken, übrigens ich habe seit einer ganzen Weile bei Strato, seit 2 Jahren
habe ich bei Strato eine 1 Euro VM, die ist performanstechnisch, die ist in Sicht eigentlich
ziemlich erschrott, aber 1 Euro pro Monat ist durchaus in Ordnung, Strato 1 Euro VM,
sowas ganz billiges habe ich mir mal, ach sag bloß die gibt es nicht mehr, sag bloß
die gibt es nicht mehr die 1 Euro VM, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht wie das heißt, oder
war das 1 und 1, es kann auch 1 und 1 gewesen sein, ich bin mir da gar nicht mehr sicher,
irgendwas, ja halt richtiger Schrott, aber ist halt billig, ich habe da beispielsweise
einen MQTT Server drauf laufen, so ein paar ganz kleine Sachen, ach was, Ionost war das,
du hast recht, nicht Strato, ich bringe das alles durcheinander, 1 Euro VPS, dann die
waren es glaube ich, die waren das glaube ich, ja nicht Strato, bei denen habe ich glaube
ich sowas ganz kleines, aber Moment, Moment, meins kostet nicht 2 Euro, meins kostet 1
Euro im Monat, das weiß ich genau, weil das ist der einzige Grund warum ich das abgeschlossen
habe, das ist aber genau, das ist Schert, das ist Schert, du kriegst das nicht, ich
glaube das gibt es nicht mehr, ich muss mal gucken nicht, dass die meine VM erhöhen
einfach, weil für 2 Euro im Monat, für 2 Euro im Monat will ich es nicht mehr, ich
will es für 1 Euro im Monat, nur noch bestanden, ja weil das gute ist bei dem 1 Euro, das
ist eine VM plus eine Public IPv4 Adresse, das ist mega nice, die werde ich für immer
behalten solange sie es nicht irgendwie kündigen, 4 Brötchen, man kriegt doch keine 4 Brötchen
heutzutage dafür oder, ok zeig mal hier, also was hat hier jemand gepostet, hier sollen
wir gucken, 2 Jahre, 1 Core, 10G, ok Traffic ist natürlich mit einem Terra TP jetzt, Alter,
für den Preis kannst du dir fast, für den Preis kannst du dir fast eine Festplatte kaufen
damit, ok das geht dann wirklich nur für ganz kleines Zeug, kostet für 2, ok das kostet
ungefähr 1 Euro pro Monat, aber so geil finde ich es jetzt gar nicht mal, Alter, die lassen
sich aber auch alles mega bezahlen oder, Alter, jetzt ist es ja gut, ach Moment, sind das
Jahrespreise, ach ne das sind 2 Jahrespreise, ich sag nichts, das sind die Preise für 2
Jahre oder, ja dann ist es doch tatsächlich ok, dann ist es tatsächlich doch ganz ok,
ist das nur ein Container oder eine echte VM, ja gut letztendlich kriegt man was man bezahlt
bei so Anbietern, also da darf man jetzt nichts Großes erwarten, aber wenn man halt da auch
nichts Großes damit machen will, so 1 Euro pro Monat schon ziemlich günstig, wieso wird
CPU immer nur in Cores angegeben, in was willst du das denn sonst angeben, ach du meinst dass
die nicht sagen, das ist ein Ryzen 5600 mit so und so viel Gigahertz oder sowas, na wahrscheinlich
weil das schlicht und ergreifend variieren kann worauf du läufst, die werden dir wahrscheinlich
nichts spezielles garantieren können, ja genau das denke ich mir auch, ich mein die werden
diese billig VMs eh schon nicht auf den allergeilsten Clustern laufen lassen, aber es kann ja durchaus
auch sein, dass du migriert wirst deine VM, also so nach dem Motto sie haben aktuell wenig
Traffic, dann bekommst du halt bisschen mehr Performance auf bessere Hardware oder sie
haben alles ausverkauft gerade, dann kommst du halt auf die letzte im letzten hinteren
Rack auf irgendeine Kiste von vor 15 Jahren läufst du dann, wahrscheinlich können sie
das schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht garantieren, ja ist aber bei großen Cloud Anbietern nicht
so viel anders, die machen das alle nur in Cores, ich glaube sogar Hetzner sind eine
der wenigen die dabei schreiben ob das AMD oder Intel Cores überhaupt sind, ich glaube
bei Hetzner ist es ein bisschen Marketing, weil im Endeffekt ist es mir eigentlich ziemlich
egal ob das Intel oder AMD Cores sind, also eigentlich ist es mir persönlich total egal
ob ich auf AMD Cores oder Intel Cores laufe, ja bei Microsoft geht das, da musst du auswählen,
die Dinger sind halt wieder, die Dinger sind halt bescheuert, bescheuert benahmt, bei Microsoft
heißen die Dinger dann keine Ahnung M2V oder so komisches Zeug, da musst du nachgucken
ah M2V ist mit AMD CPUs und sowas, aber hier steht es dran, ne mach keinen Unterschied,
es ist letztendlich egal, ehrlich gesagt also mich würde es persönlich überhaupt nicht
interessieren worauf meine VM läuft und welchen Core ich kriege, performanstechnisch, du kommst
ja mit VMs eigentlich die CPU Performance ist ja nicht so als bist du da regelmäßig
immer am 100% Limit, ja genau ich auch nicht, ich mein vielleicht irgendwelche Transcoding
Sachen und so, wobei das vielleicht der VM eh nicht benutzen kannst, ja ne also ich wüsste
jetzt auch nicht, ich würde das nehmen was preisleistungstechnisch am besten ist, so
siehts aus, so jetzt erkläre ich euch mal was wir heute machen und zwar wir machen heute
die letzten 3 Challenges, das hatten wir die Ache einmal von gestern, wir machen noch die
letzten 3 Challenges von Set Servers, wenn ich weiß was das ist übrigens ihr könnt
wenn euch das gefällt könnt ihr auf GitHub dem mal ein paar Sterne geben, der hat es
auf jeden Fall verdient, ich mein ich will auch nicht dem seine AWS Rechnungen wissen
am Ende des Monats, der Hintergrund der ist nice gell, hab ich den da, oh gut komm mal
und hier schimmert er sogar ein bisschen durch im Terminal und hier sieht man schon also
er schreibt ja schon was es ist, troubleshoot and make a Set Server happy, das machen wir
heute und die weitere Erklärung ist Lead Code for Linux, capture the flag challenges, train
and prove your debugging skills, practice your next devops interview, get a full remote Linux
server with a problem and fix it, also letztendlich sieht das ganze so aus, es gibt 18 Aufgaben
und bei jeder Aufgabe wenn man hier auf run drückt, also bei jeder Aufgabe an einer gewisser
Zeit und wenn man hier auf run drückt dann, ach guck mal der hatte jetzt auch die Types
hier hinten zur Auswahl, fix, was ist denn do, fix do, achso mache irgendwas, mache
irgendwas ganz und hier Hacker Kram, was haben wir denn überhaupt noch offen, den mache
ich nicht da habe ich keinen Bock drauf auf kooperiertes Zeug gerade, was ist denn, was
haben wir denn überhaupt noch offen, das da SSH haben wir offen, das haben wir offen,
haben wir nur noch zwei offen, kann das sogar sein, das haben wir schon, wobei haben wir
das, haben wir das schon gemacht, das haben wir schon gemacht oder, oder ich kann mich
jetzt gar nicht richtig dran erinnern, ach da war das Limit, ah ok, ok dann haben wir
noch offen, dann haben wir noch offen 16, 17, 18 oder, das haben wir noch nicht gemacht,
das haben wir noch nicht gemacht, haben wir SSH schon gemacht, ne das haben wir auch noch
nicht gemacht, das kommt mir auch nicht bekannt vor, also 16, 17, 18 haben wir, also sprich
das sind Aufgaben für Linux Benutzer, Linux Admins unterschiedliche Schwierigkeitsgrade
von einfach bis schwer, ich kann es euch ja nochmal zeigen, also für alle, für alle
die nicht da gewesen sind, ich zeige euch nochmal wie das ganze aussieht, also es gibt
eine Aufgabe zum Beispiel, oh Moment, haha da hab ich mich nicht vergessen, sonst leake
ich wieder, sonst leake ich wieder die Server ID, also folgendermaßen funktioniert das,
man bekommt, man bekommt eine Aufgabe, was, man bekommt eine Aufgabe, zum Beispiel ein
Entwickler hat ein Testprogramm erstellt, das kontinuierlich in eine Log Datei schreibt,
warlog, bedlog und die Festplatte vorläuft, sie können das zum Beispiel mit tail-f bla
bla bla bla, was auch immer überprüfen, dieses Programm wird nicht mehr benötigt, finden
sie es und beenden sie es, das muss ich jetzt machen, dafür habe ich 10 Minuten Zeit und
am Ende gibt es hier einen Check, Check my Solution Button, der guckt ob ich das richtig
gemacht habe, also ich klicke jetzt hier drauf, dann kriege ich einen Link zu einer VM, das
ist eine echte Azure VM und da kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel den Testbefehl hier ausführen
und stelle fest, ok in der Log Datei wird tatsächlich permanent irgendwas reingeschrieben,
das heißt ich gucke mir das ganze mal an und sage lsof, aha es ist anscheinend badlog.py,
was da rein schreibt, pitt 501, dann kille ich die pitt und das schreibt nicht mehr in
die Log Datei rein, jetzt warte ich 6 Sekunden und wenn 6 Sekunden um sind klicke ich auf
Check my Solution, dann sagt das korrekt, alles gut, Aufgabe gelöst, so funktioniert
das, passt alles gut und dann kann ich weitermachen, das war jetzt die erste Aufgabe, die ist mega
simpel gewesen, die anderen waren schon etwas schwerer, ich glaube sogar hier war das mit
dem Wordpress, da habe ich sogar in 20 Minuten nicht hingekriegt, ich glaube man hat verstanden
was es geht oder, also es gibt Aufgaben die man in einer bestimmten Zeit lösen soll und
wenn man es geschafft hat, hat man es geschafft, gibt es da keine Belohnung oder so für, gibt
da auch keine Top-Listen und sowas und was gibt es da sonst noch irgendwas zu sagen,
ich glaube nicht, 10 Minuten Aufgabe innerhalb von 15 Sekunden erledigt, ja gut.
Die Aufgabe ist erstens total easy und zweitens habe ich die jetzt schon 5 mal gemacht um
es zu zeigen wie es funktioniert, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Power Off und Halt,
ich muss ehrlich sagen keine Ahnung, ich würde fast vermuten, dass mittlerweile beides das
gleiche macht, ich kenne auch den Effekt von früher, dass wenn du Halt gemacht hast, dass
der Rechner sich nicht ausgeschaltet hat, je nach A, wie heißt das Ding A, CPI oder
so, Config, übrigens soll ich euch mal richtigen Hacker-Man Shit zeigen, wenn ihr mal auf
einer Linux Kiste seid, ich mache das mal kurz mit meiner VM, mit meiner VM kann da
nichts kaputt gehen, ok pass mal auf, wenn ihr mal auf einer Linux Kiste seid und die
hat irgendwie Probleme, dass sie nicht rebootet, dass sie hängt, aber ihr kommt noch drauf,
das ist natürlich die Voraussetzung dafür, es ist egal ob ihr da per SSH oder per Terminal
drauf kommt, Hauptsache sie funktioniert im Prinzip noch so, dass man was eingeben kann,
also sie hängt, sie fährt nicht richtig runter oder aber was auch manchmal vorkommt, dass
euer Chef sagt alles ausschalten, nach Möglichkeit so, dass nichts mehr geschrieben wird und so
was, dann gibt es einen Trick, den kennen nicht so viele, deswegen zeige ich euch den
mal an, hat meiner VM, es gibt einen geheimen, es gibt ein, nee das meine ich nicht, was
ähnliches, aber es gibt eine geheime Datei, was heißt geheime, die geheime ist die nicht,
die gibt es auf jedem Linux System, aber die ist nicht so bekannt, es gibt eine, ich nenne
es mal geheime Datei und zwar, ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher, Sys, Brock, nee Trigger,
wie hieß das Ding, Sys, nee warte mal, Brock Sys, ich weiß es gerade aus dem Kopf, ja,
das meine ich, Brock Sys, das meine ich, Brock Sys RQ Trigger, die Datei, so und da müssen
wir mal in die Hilfe gucken davon, man kann in die Datei verschiedene Sachen reinschreiben,
zum Beispiel kann man da reinschreiben, minus O, kann man O reinschreiben, will shut your
system off, oder du hast sowas wie B, will immediately reboot system without syncing or
mounting your disk, also wenn ihr einfach euer System ausschalten wollt, bzw. neu starten
wollt und ihr sicher gehen wollt, dass nichts mehr ausgeführt wird, dass einfach neu gestartet
könnt ihr sagen, Echo B nach Brock Sys RQ Trigger und Achtung, sobald ich Enter drücke,
Bäm, da wird nix runtergefahren, nix gesynced, einfach, guck mal, sogar meine Festplatte
muss einen Health Check machen nach dem Reboot, war tatsächlich öfters jetzt die letzten
Jahre über, ich muss das unbedingt mal als Pull Request, ich muss das unbedingt mal als
Pull Request einreichen bei denen, dass nicht immer, dass nicht immer meine Leiste da oben
kaputt geht, Wim, Core, ne, Core Modules, das ist nämlich verbacht, das liegt da, meine
Python Version ist zu neu, da muss es so aussehen die Zeit, dann funktioniert meine Statusleister
wieder, total bescheuert, also das könnt ihr euch tatsächlich merken, wenn ihr mal Probleme
habt auf wegen der Linux Kiste, wir machen noch die letzten drei Aufgaben Set-Servers,
die hier, da könnt ihr alles das machen mit der Datei, ihr könnt übrigens euer System
auch crashen, wer noch nie, Moment, Sekunde, wer noch nie einen Colonel Panic gesehen hat,
ich mein, Linux crasht ja jetzt relativ selten, ja, Linux crasht ja nicht so oft, aber ihr
könnt zum Beispiel sagen, C nach Borg sus RQ Trigger und wer schon immer mal einen Colonel
Panic sehen wollte, sieht keinen Colonel Panic, aber mein System ist am abkacken, geht nicht
mehr, also wer Glück hat, sieht einen Colonel Panic, aber meine Tastatur blinkt wie verrückt
gerade und jetzt ist es halt komplett, komplett gecrashed, jetzt muss ich wirklich Reset machen,
dass es funktioniert, du weißt nicht zufällig, wie die es crashen, doch steht doch in der
Hilfe Datei, die greifen auf den Pointer zu, auf null Pointer, die sagen quasi, Sternchen,
die Reference von null, so und dann crasht das ganze, moin Fips, jetzt haben wir aber
genug Linux Sachen gecrashed, machen wir Setgeservers, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie nice ich das finde,
diese Anzeige von der CPU-Auslastung hier oben, guck mal, richtig, hat was richtig meditatives,
seinem Rechner so zuzugucken bei der CPU-Auslastung pro Kern, der Background, ich muss mal meinen
Designer fragen, wie weiter ist mit dem anderen Kram, ich habe ja bei meinem Designer beauftragt,
der die Thumbnails macht, ob er diesen Hintergrund nicht noch achtmal anfertigen kann, also ich
schicke ihm den Hintergrund und er macht da acht Versionen raus, Pepo nachts mit Sternen
am Himmel beim Schlafen, morgens beim Frühstücken, mittags beim Essen, beim Arbeiten, beim Formcomputer
hocken und sowas, dass man quasi den ganzen Tag über den Bildschirm immer passend zur
Tageszeit hat, kannst du das veröffentlichen als PLG, das mache ich, wenn die anderen
Sachen fertig sind, wenn es die andere Version gibt, weil dann mache ich mir das auch mit
acht, acht verschiedenen Versionen im Hintergrund, so, das kannst du je nach Zeit dann automatisch
updaten, ja, das ist ja, das ist ja die Idee dahinter, die ich, die ich habe, so, also
gucken wir uns mal die Aufgabe, wo wir stehen geblieben, Chet, ihr dürft entscheiden, wir
haben diese, wir haben diese Aufgaben noch offen, wir haben zur Auswahl Probleme mit
dem Schreiben, Schreiben in Datenbanken, dann haben wir irgendwelche SSH Verbindungen,
die nicht funktionieren und wir haben Hacker Web Server, auf 15 habe ich keinen Bock auf
kombiniertes Stells, ich habe mir in dem, liegt, liegt glaube ich auch daran, weil das
Docker Beispiel ein bisschen gebadet war, Docker Beispiel habe ich die Zeit gerissen
von 20 Minuten, aber ich habe es hingekriegt, das war ziemlich ja gebadet, ich weiß es
nicht mehr richtig, die hatten das Problem, es waren das Problem mit der Docker Geschichte,
die hatten glaube ich das Problem, dass es keine Namensauflösung gab, weil es auf der
Default Bridge hingen, was ist Set Servers, ok, ich erkläre es einmal noch für alle die
reingekommen sind, aber dann ist gut, weil wir müssen irgendwann mal anfangen, also
Set Servers ist so eine Übungsplattform für, also steht ja im Prinzip hier, Like Lead
Code nur für Linux, also es gibt hier verschiedene Aufgaben, aktuell gibt es 18 verschiedene
Aufgaben, die ist ja hier von 1, 1 ist easy, also sozusagen easy, also 1 ist so easy, dass
ich 15 Sekunden brauche für die 10 Minuten Aufgabe, da gibt es verschiedene Übungen,
man hat für jede Übung nur eine gewisse Zeit, wenn man die Zeit überschreitet, schaltet
sich die VM einfach ab, das heißt du kannst dann auch nicht weitermachen, dann schaltet
sich die VM aus, und hier siehst du die Aufgabe was du machen musst und wenn du auf Run drückst
kriegst du die Aufgabe und kannst dich auf eine AWS VM connecten, oder die Zuschauer
schalten die VM ab, deswegen sorgen wir dafür, dass die Leute die VM nicht sehen können.
So, also dann wollen wir eine Umfrage machen, Leute soll ich eine Umfrage machen oder wollen
wir einfach mit 18 anfangen, also wir haben die Auswahl 16, 17 oder 18, sag ichs da fällt
noch keiner mehr rein, ok ich mach mal ne Umfrage, Max du musst nicht, ich mach schon, ok welche
Challenge soll ich machen, soll Max machen, Fragezeichen 16, 17, 18, allow additional
votes mit Keksen, ok wir müssen mal ein bisschen Channel, wir müssen mal ein bisschen Kekse
loswerden, man kann mit tausend Keksen, kann man einmal extra abstimmen, muss ja auch ein
bisschen was kosten, frag doch ChatGPT, da muss ich mich erstmal wieder einloggen, ok,
so ich lasse es mal hier eingebläut, also 17, 18, 16, 17 oder 18.
Sag ichs, ich hab nie behauptet, das ist was anderes, ja, das ist kein demokratischer Abstimmungsprozess
hier, wer mehr Channelpunkte hat kann mir abstimmen, der Markt regelt das, genau, 18,
ok, 18 hat mit einem riesen Vorsprung gewonnen und zwar mit 75%, ganz close, sag ichs hat
ordentlich Kanalpunkte reingehauen, dann machen wir jetzt die 18, auf gehts, Sag ichs hat 28
mal abgestimmt, ahja, hätte die auch machen können, ok also 18 soll man machen, ok gut,
Aufgabe ist wie folgt, gehen wir mal wieder zu Diepel, Aufgabe ist wie folgt, Szenario,
einen Web Server, Hacker mannen, oh das darf ich so nicht auf YouTube hochladen, sonst
wird das gleich Hacking Content, Get out, Stufe schwer Typ Hack, alles klar, gut ich meine
es ist ja nur ne Übung, Beschreibung, es gibt ein Geheimnis das in einer Datei gespeichert
ist, die der lokale Apache Web Server bereitstellen kann, finden Sie dieses Geheimnis und speichern
Sie es in der Datei home-admin-secret.txt, beachten Sie, dass auf diesem Server der Benutzer
Admin kein Zu-Doer ist, ah ok, wir haben keine Admin-Rechte auf dem Server, verstehe, verstehe,
gut das machts natürlich nicht einfacher, beachten Sie auch, richtig der Hacker mein
Shit, beachten Sie auch, dass die Passwortknacker Hashcat und Hydra, haben wir das Hydra E-Mode,
ich glaube das haben wir gar nicht, ne haben wir nicht, dass die Passwortknacker Hashcat
und Hydra aus den Paketen installiert sind und die Binärdateien von John the Ripper
aus den Quellen in home-admin-john-run erstellt wurden, Hashcat kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
das habe ich schon mal benutzt, John the Ripper habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal benutzt,
das ist aber schon sehr lange her und das Tool gibt es auch schon ewig.
So und der Test ob alles funktioniert ist, das hier, ok auf gehts, hack im Web Server,
schauen wir mal, da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt drauf, was da auf uns zukommt man, ihr dürft
übrigens wieder backseiten so viel ihr wollt, wenn ihr mir aber zu sehr auf den Keks geht
kann sein, dass ich den ein oder anderen mal time oute, teilweise übertreiben es die Leute
ja extrem was backseating angeht, aber ihr dürft, ihr dürft so viel backseiten wie ihr
wollt bis zu dem Punkt wo es mir auf den Keks geht, also wenn ihr was schreiben wollt, schreibt
es, ok die vm braucht eine Weile bis die erstellt ist, da bin ich jetzt immer echt gespannt
was da auf uns zukommt hier, to save the planet some CO2 emissions, ja ok shut down, ich mach
power off, kommt aufs gleiche raus und irgendjemand Faschlingsstellts gemacht von euch heute,
ich nicht, wie gesagt ich kann mit sowas eh nix anfangen, mochte, ich mochte das noch
nie, ok auf gehts, wie viel zeit haben wir 20 minuten oder 20 minuten, 30 minuten haben
wir sogar Zeit, ok auf gehts, open, bam, gut, Zulu menosi, moment, also entweder,
ok es gibt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder hat der Typ das einfach vergessen oder das
ist Absicht, aber ich bin gut, ja also ich bin gut, scheint, ich mein vielleicht ist
der Trick auch, vielleicht ist der Trick ja auch, dass man nicht alles glauben soll was
da drin steht, kann doch auch sein, ok also was sollen wir machen, there is a secret stored
in a file that the local apache webserver can provide, ok, netstat, apache läuft auf
port 80, local host, unauthorized, ok das geht ja schon gut los, jetzt natürlich die
Frage, nutzen wir das aus, dass wir doch gut sein dürfen oder nicht, ich überleg grad
wie man am besten basic auth bruteforced, bin auch für ausnutzen, ok also gehen wir
mal wahr, wir können ja wenn wir Zeit haben gucken, wir können es ja nachher nochmal
machen und gucken ob wir das anderweitig raus bekommen, so wirklich einen gescheiten Ansatz
pauschal hätte ich jetzt nicht, wir gucken erstmal wie weit wir so kommen und dann schauen
wir, ok www, html, was haben wir da liegen, webfile, cat, webfile, secret txt, ok, was
ist minus c, ok das ist, das ist irgendwas, Schlüssel das, vielleicht, was ist denn das,
das ist, ach ein zip ist das, ok interessant, kopieren wir uns das mal, cp war www, html,
webfile, kopieren wir uns mal nach root, unzip, webfile, webfile, secret password, ok verstehe,
ok jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich, das ist ein Verschluss, wir müssen jetzt rauskriegen,
ich mach jetzt einfach hackerman, ich tippe jetzt einfach alle Passwörter durch, bis ich
das Richtige gefunden hab, 123456, nein funktioniert nicht, ok also jetzt müssen wir, jetzt müssen
wir hashcat benutzen und john the ripper und so, ehrlich gesagt ich habe aus dem Kopf
absolut nicht den plassten Schimmer, wie diese, wie diese Tools funktionieren, aber wir machen
einfach mal hash, hashcat, zipfile, wir machen john the ripper, zipfile, wir googeln das,
ich hab keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf wie man den kram benutzt, how to cracking zip on a
project, ok nice so machen wir das, cracking zip on jar, on ra protected files on the ripper,
ok nice gucken wir uns, wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns einen Guide an wie das funktioniert,
in the run folder, achso ok gehen wir mal, home, admin, john, oder gibt es ein run verzeichnet,
ok schon mal ganz interessant, ne wir müssen hier eigentlich bleiben, wir müssen home,
admin, john, ok wie funktioniert das jetzt, in the run folder of john the ripper oder
wir können auch mal hashcat, hashcat gucken, in the run folder of john the ripper community
version there are two programs called zip to john and ra to john, run them against their
respective files types to extract the password hashes, aha, ne googeln ist erlaubt, wenn
google nicht erlaubt ist, ist doch bescheuert, ok also was brauchen wir, run und was gibt
es dann, zip, zip to john und das soll man jetzt auf webfile machen, ah und da kommen
jetzt die password hashes raus, ok das heisst das muss ich umleiten in, ja zip, zip, Punkt
hashes, ok, zip Punkt hashes da steht das jetzt drinne, alles klar und wie gehts jetzt
weiter, home, admin, john, run und das auf zip Punkt hashes, ok, easy, andis, wie das
war es jetzt schon, mehr brauchen wir nicht, andis, unzip, webfile, andis, easy, secret
Punkt txt, na gut das war jetzt wirklich, bis jetzt war das wirklich nicht so schwierig,
hat secret Punkt txt, das war es oder, ja das kann, Moment, ich glaube wenn sudo nicht
gegangen wäre, wäre das deutlich komplizierter gewesen, ok gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal
ob das, ob das stimmt, ob das, ob das richtig ist, char one sum secret, ja das ist richtig,
ok challenge, challenge geschafft, das war bestimmt so nicht gedacht, das war bestimmt
nicht gedacht, nee ohne root wäre ich aber nicht an die Datei drangekommen, solution
is correct, ok wir haben ja noch Zeit, wir sind jetzt in 7 Minuten durch gewesen, ok
das mit root, das mit root kann es nicht so gewesen sein, das mit root kann es ja wirklich
nicht so gewesen sein, ok wie könnte man das machen, curl, localhost, wir haben nicht
die credentials, cackle, ups, wir haben nicht die credentials, so ich hab keine Ahnung
wie man basic auth irgendwie root forcen kann, muss man basic auth irgendwie, vielleicht
kann ich aber auch auf var ww so zugreifen, wait a minute, nee, nee geht nicht oder, exist
denied, ahja, ok nee das funktioniert nicht, dann müsste es eine htpass wd geben, ja möglich,
aber da werd ich ja auch nicht drauf zugreifen können, oder vielleicht doch, mal gucken,
cat, nehmen wir mal, curl, das wird ja, htpass das wird ja so nicht funktionieren, mal die
conf checken, etc, apache 2, da hab ich aber auch keine rechte drauf oder, oh doch da hab
ich rechte drauf, ok sides, guck mal was da sonst noch so rum liegt, htpass wd, moment
da hab ich read rechte drauf, ok das ist schonmal ne blöde ide, dass ich da read rechte
drauf hab, das sollte man nicht machen, ok ich hab doch, carlos, carlos, pass wd, ach
ich bin gar nicht in meinem heimat verzeichnet, sagt es doch einer, ich denk mir die ganze
Zeit, ok hier haben wir pass wd, ok dann müssen wir mal, john, john the ripper, htpass wd,
ok ok, ok pass wg, ok dann muss ich das gleich mal aufnehmen, ok und nosejonesック hab
Ne
Detecting blabla blupf okay mach ich mal
Format md5 kripp long ich habe serious lika
Ich habe steuerung w gedrückt
Ich habe steuerung wie gedrückt aber gut es ist ja doch alles da also john run
ht pass wd und was muss man jetzt machen
Und was muss man jetzt machen
Ich rate das jetzt einfach ich habe keine ahnung wie man die tools gescheit benutzt
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal nicht kann man den hasch vielleicht einfach extrahieren
Dass man einfach sagt wie gesagt ich habe keine ahnung wenn es benutzt kann man den hasch einfach
Kann man den hasch einfach
Oder muss ich da jetzt mit haschkett ran
Datei rechts sind richtig oder muss ich da jetzt mit haschkett ran
Das ist nur fürs lock und wahrscheinlich auch weil ich da vorher mit root mit root drin rum gewurstet habe
Moment moment wir fixen wir fixen gerade mal wieder das was wir vorhin kaputt gemacht haben
Eomen
Quatsch
Okay
Das log charted komm los charlis ok ja wir haben wir ich hab vorhin die die rechte von dem verzeichnis kaputt gemacht
also localholes
das heißt wir haben die carlos marthaus from new york city oder was hat er erzählt
genau der tut alter wie hieß er noch mal carlos mit connect genau
ich habe keine ahnung wie irgendjemand auf diesen scam reinfallen konnte hat
das wirklich jemand geguckt und sich gedacht und das wirkt aber so seriös den den akumulator
hacken lernen mit dem florian jetzt kann man sagen er hat sich das wirklich irgendjemand
angeguckt hat sich gedacht aber das ist so so seriös das ist so seriös da will ich jetzt
unbedingt bei meinen geld reinstecken was so was so was so was so was so was so was so
carlos ok also wir müssen uns jetzt erst mal anmelden hier carlos doppelpunkt charlotte
ad localhost und schon haben wir die basic or überwunden und können bekommen eine webseite
zurück eine viertelstunde zeit kann ich das kurz beantworten noch mal eine rückfrage
zum windows share einbinden fallen wir folgen aber viel liefert mount europa mission den
eins zu du bist du neid das ist immer ein bisschen eklig windows sachen zu mounten user password
fragt er dich überhaupt nach einem password fragt er dich überhaupt nach einem password
muss er nicht noch machen minus o password oder so dass er dich überhaupt nach dem password
fragt du bist am password gefragt versuch das mal zu quaten versuch versuch deinen share
mal zu quaten und probierst dann mal mit viele was backslashes also single quote das auf
jeden fall auf jeden fall mal das ding hier ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt auch gar nicht
minus o user doch eigentlich ganz ganz brauchbar aus wobei ich also ich würde es nicht unter
mnt gibt es gibt es mnt share ich würde es nicht unter mnt share machen weil da kann
dein user nicht drauf zugreifen single quotes gleiches problem dann weiß ich aus dem kopf
auch nicht sommer mountain ist immer ein bisschen eklig kannst du mal mit backslashes probieren
aber weiß ich jetzt auch weiß ich jetzt auch gar aus dem kopf nichts zu so also was
haben wir denn hier zu bieten es gibt eine html seite als response mit bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla hier webfile slash webfile easy ok leute ab jetzt ab jetzt ist es genau genau
das gleiche wie das andere webfile ja das ist genau das ok ab jetzt ist es das gleiche
ab jetzt ist das gleiche das müssen wir jetzt nicht machen das ist genau das gleiche also
jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich die datei die ich vorher parut rüber kopiert habe ok also
dafür habe ich keine 13 minuten gebraucht keine keine 30 minuten gebraucht webfile
ist das zipp genau es ist wieder das zipp was war jetzt daran hart jetzt war hacker man
shit das per definition hart ich muss aber auch sagen ich glaube ich wäre erst mal nicht
auf die idee gekommen hätte nicht jemand im chat was von ht pass wd oder so geschrieben
wäre ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht auf die idee gekommen jetzt mal unter etc apache zu
gucken ob die datei da liegt und wer sich jetzt freut und denkt geil damit kann ich
jetzt alle webserver hacker mann könnt ihr nicht die passwörter waren absichtlich easy
as fuck sechsstellig und wahrscheinlich auch in irgendeiner passwortliste drinne bei ordentlich
langen passwörtern habt ihr da wahrscheinlich gelitten und md5 ist auch keine gute idee
zum haschen das kommt ja noch dabei das sind zwei sachen wobei in dem fall ist es egal
und vor allem brauchst du ssh access da drauf er gut nicht zwangsläufig das hier hätte
ich jetzt auch von meiner kiste ausführen können hätte ich zugriff auf den webserver
gab dass er funktioniert das wäre möglich gewesen der erste schritt md ht access datei
die ht pass wd bekommen nicht also insofern ja so wirklich wirklich richtig realitätsnah
ist es nicht aber easy easy können wir auch abhaken power off haben wir gelöst kann man
nur sagen easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy alles klar war das auch geschafft
auch hängen bekommen zeit für noch eine wir haben ganz viel zeit wir machen jetzt
die restlichen ordnung wenn ich das schon sehe alle die jäckchen sind unterwegs leute
die jäckchen dieses wort ist schon das wort alleine fällt mir schon schwer auszusprechen
weil ich das so weil ich diesen ganzen faschings kram so bescheuert finde die jäckchen sind
unterwegs die sind an zwei tagen die sind an zwei tagen im jahr lustig die sind an fasching
lustig und am ersten april lustig ansonsten sind die leute den das ganze jahr über nicht
lustig also die kecken die keck w nur zwei mal im jahr am ersten april und zu fasching
das sind wir im twitch chat natürlich deutlich überlegen weil wir können so oft keck w
und das gesamte jahr über wie wir wollen und wir haben vor allem auch noch mehr alternativen
wir können keck w wir können keck keck keckeln wir können null oder sogar null 3d also wir
haben da schon viel vielfältigere sachen übrigens wusstet ihr das chat gpt einfach
wieder dreist dreist am lügen ist was was seht ihr hier leute bei diesem emote was was
erkennt ihr da ich sage euch gleich was chat ich habe chat gpt gefragt ich habe chat gpt
gefragt was man bei diesem was man beim emote gachi bass sieht ihr seht gachi bass ich sehe
auch gachi bass ich habe ich habe ich habe chat gpt gefragt was man sieht und chat gpt
gesagt pass mal auf hier nur mal so hier chat gpt sagt gachi bass ist ein emote aus der
twitch community das ist soweit schon mal richtig und wird oft als ausdruck von begeisterung
oder unterstützung verwendet das emote zeigt einen muskulösen mann mit einem schnurbad
der eine kappe und eine sonnenbrille trägt und einen daumen nach oben zeigt es wird oft
in verbindung mit musik streams insbesondere edm und techno verwendet also nicht ganz nicht
ganz das stimmt halt ja gut gachi bass vielleicht meistens wird gachi bass aber nicht wirklich
für musik verwendet vielleicht vom ein oder anderen eigentlich ist gachi bass eher die
animiertere variante von gachi gazem richtig richtig lost chat gpt wieder
das beste jep cock gut machen wir die nächste challenge was haben wir denn jetzt hong kong
can't write data into database ja vielleicht auch besser so für hong kong pokhara ssh ok
wir machen ssh wir machen 17 wir machen 17 ok was ist die aufgabe die aufgabe ist schwer
auf jeden fall schon mal wenn ich einen kleinen hetzer server habe macht es sinn docker für
webseiten einzusetzen oder lieber engine x direkt auf die maschine laufen lassen macht
das große performance unterschiede also wenn du einfach nur statischen content da drauf
haben willst da kannst du den engine x drauf machen und fertig ist da hat jetzt docker
als erst mal vor allem wenn sich das nicht so viel wenn sich das jetzt nicht so oft ändert
wenn du
ein bisschen komplexere anwendung hast die nicht nur statische webseiten sind wo noch
ein bisschen mehr dazugehört da kann das durchaus sinn machen das in docker laufen
zu lassen oder oder wenn du zwar statischen content hast aber irgendwie da woanders das
bauen willst erst also es gibt ja heute viele so statis static site generator dass du dann
sagst ok ich ich check hier was ein generiere mir das bau dann ein image draus aber man
muss es ja nicht gleich komplett übertreiben mit containerisierung also wenn du einfach
nur eine handvoll statischer seiten hast wo sich alle schalter mal was dran ändert machen
engine x drauf und gut ist solltest du allerdings automatisches ssl und sowas haben wollen
da könntest du dir vielleicht auch gedanken machen tatsächlich über docker setup automatisches
ssl das funktioniert auch alles mit engine x und surport und solche geschichten ist keine
frage aber da kannst du jetzt vielleicht überlegen ob du sowas wie fünf docker container und
den traffic davor nimmst und das automatisch machen lässt oder du machst mit cany direkt
ja aber man muss es nicht man muss es nicht übertreiben ja chat gpt hat was sowas angeht
wenig plan ok also was machen wir jetzt ein benutzer wurde dem server was ein benutzer
kleint ane ein user mit dem namen kleint wurde dem server hinzugefügt ebenso wie sein
öffentliche ssh schlüssel das ziel ist es sich lokal es gibt nur einen server als dieser
kleint benutzer mit seinem ssh schlüssel anmelden zu können das heißt wenn sie als
root zu diesem benutzer sudo su su klarer blablabla sollten sie in lage sein sich mit
ssh anzumelden ssh lokal host als benutzer admin sudo minus u kleint ssh blablabla ok
also das ist das ist der test das ist der test dann probieren das mal aus das könnte
jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter werden immer gespannt was er sich da ausgedacht hat ich
hoffe ich hoffe ja wirklich präge leute dass er uns nicht wieder mit irgendwelchen ip tables
rules verarschen will oder wieder zeit zurücksetzen ja zeit zurücksetzen hatten wir auch schon
war auch in einer aufgabe drin wo das zertifikat abgelaufen ist systemzeit zurücksetzen dass
das ssh zertifikat nicht das ssh hatte tps nicht ssh nur hatte tps drauf zugreifen soll
das ist dass das zertifikat abgelaufen ist aber ich habe 2021 auch schon kein battle royal
und zeug gestreamt oft aber bald will mich jetzt nicht so sehr beschweren dass es ist
ein kostenloser server auf aws schon nope gesehen was ist das nö kenne ich nicht taugt
das nopas schmack sage ok auf gehts wir resetten die zeit 30 minuten zeit ne doch 30 minuten
zeit ok bamm auf gehts new window zack ok also unser test ist folgender wir testen erstmal
ob der test auch wirklich fehlen schlägt unser test ist folgender ok das funktioniert schon
mal nicht das ist aber nicht weiter will die musik ist mir gerade ein bisschen zu anstrengend
ich brauche ein bisschen was entspannendes die geht gerade die geht gerade voll ab und
ich brauche jetzt auch nicht brauche ich jetzt auch nicht relaxen relaxen mario music mix
flexing sehr relaxen doch besser noch mehr relaxen ja jetzt können wir erst das hart
zeug machen das viel bessere musikuntermalung ok also was haben wir hier für probleme gut
wir ignorieren wir ignorieren einfach mal ssh minus ob strick strick host key checking
no passwords authentification ist das eben das ist mir auch nicht schlimm ich mein wir
können es auch ich habe browser tabs durchgespielt ich habe browser tabs durchgespielt ich habe
mehrfach browser tabs durchgespielt na hier ist nicht so viel ok also das funktioniert
schon mal nett das wird aber auch an anderen das wird aber auch an anderen sachen liegen
könnte ich wetten das liegt nicht einfach nur daran ok werden wir mal gut also was wir
tatsächlich machen können das ist tatsächlich das ist tatsächlich eine gute idee home home
wie es da kleint ssh non-host machen wir mal weg und jetzt führen wir das ganze noch mal
aus permanent added log raus ok das funktioniert nicht kann man kann man t-marks auch fack warum
hat er immer kein t-marks drauf ok also da ist schon mal prinzipiell irgendwas kaputt
wir können ssh noch mal mit ein bisschen debug ausführen ob uns das was bringt ich bezweifle
jetzt allerdings no such file or directory offering public key das sieht jetzt alles
wie viele keys hatten da tut da liegen würde schön include also das hat wahrscheinlich
es ist noch kein großes das hat wahrscheinlich nichts auszusagen an der stelle da geht wahrscheinlich
noch mehr nicht es lag gerade extrem lag das stream auch oder es ist einfach nur die
verbindung zu aws die extrem lag so wie geht es mal was gucken war log secure nee gibt
es nicht aber nicht zu bieten aus log kann man mal reingucken ist das halbwegs neuer 16 20 ok
was haben wir da drinnen zu bieten user kleint ist not allowed because listed in deny users ok
das ist schon immer so nicht gedacht etc ssh ssh d konfig das drin deny users nie da ist es nicht
wo steht denn das da setpunkt konf ok die nai user kleint so war schon mal der erste debate von ihm
dann probieren das ganze doch noch mal aus sekunde ziel permissions aha es geht weiter es geht
weiter permissions 06 für 4 ja das geht so auch nicht das sollte 6 00 sein am besten
06 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
habe ich habe ich gerade die permissions kaputt gemacht mit meinem mit meinem ch mod
irgendwie ist eigentlich ok löschen wir das doch noch mal was er dann sagt
moin andreas gucken wir doch noch mal non haus was hat was er dafür schmerzen
well to add the house to the list of non haus
stimmt auf directory ist tatsächlich blöd hat sie kann sie ja gar nicht mehr rein
das hat das tatsächlich das tatsächlich eine blöde idee gewesen vielleicht sollte
man das auch 744 machen an der stelle 7 00 wir machen 7 00 und sagen allerdings
hier die er ist ob das wüsste jetzt am besten passen weiter geht's
ich bin das systemadministrator der wurde hiermit kontaktiert wie war das jetzt user
mod wie war user info noch mal anzeigen das braucht man so selten man das weiß
doch keiner aus dem kopf man die wollen wieder zeug wissen
linux display user info oder machen wir was anderes was tschage ich glaube euch
das display user account und info wir fragen google jawohl google weiß das
all die ja das get end nee das heißt übrigens get net es heißt get end was
der übrigens hier auch richtig macht
nene nene nene da gab es doch da gab es aber was anderes
wir machen was anderes linux change expired reset expired user reset password
expired ja genau das sieht doch gut aus pass wd das ergibt könnte es tatsächlich sein
pass aber moment nee nee nee nee das nicht das was ich haben will
das will ich haben tatsächlich tschage oder change age oder was soll das
heißen seriously habe ich noch nie benutzt ich
mache den graben seit 15 jahren ich habe nicht einmal glaube ich tschage verwendet
change user password expiry information tschage tschage wie spricht man das
überhaupt aus ok weg wir können auch tschage minus l machen kleint ok da
steht das password alles der account ist unix time expired
ist es ist es change age wahrscheinlich ok es ist das kann man nur richtig
aussprechen expire 30 days from now ok nice moment ich will nicht das password
ich will ich das password ich will wann der account expired ich will minus e
haben ich will ich will minus e haben und dann ja keine ahnung 2023 zwölfter
zwölfter würde ich sagen ja kleint das sieht schon besser aus
wo wir das ganze noch mal request fällt und schenkt ich leute ich weiß der typ
der typ macht wieder krasses tschibet ich wette mit euch da ist irgendwas nicht
da ist in den in den login shell oder so ein müll eingetragen 100 pro das ist
das ist so typischer tschibet der man den man macht wenn man azubis nerven will
und so was ja guck hier sage ich doch klein no login ja super nice gg eats ok
das heißt aber auch wenn ich mache soo minus klein da geht das nicht weil
resource temporary unavailable nicht nicht da ok also dass das allein ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht doch dass das wird sein so rum ok
tragen wir es direkt hier ein bin bärsch bin bärsch hock nächstes
ok nächster nächster tschibet versuch user limits nächster tschibet versuch
user limits limits ich weiß es ist das ist das ich weiß dass man das du musst
übrigens gar nicht soo minus erst mal du kannst einfach sagen
sudo minus sudo minus u kleint bin bärsch geht auch
by the way dass sudo minus in der challenge war tatsächlich nicht so
gedacht wird wohl jetzt gefixt wie wird jetzt wohl gefixt ist irgendjemand zu
dem entwickler geflitzt hat gesagt der wobblers streamt das gerade mal fest
gestellt dass sudo geht oder was was ist was ist mit dem chat wieder los
ist ernsthaft gleich gepetzt oder was
ist ja der chat ist wieder am chat ist am chatting betreiben aber ist auch gut
ist auch gut dass ihr das gemeldet habt wir haben das jetzt ausgenutzt und jetzt
kann es gefixt werden finde ich finde ich gut
ich wollte user limits nachgucken ich wette leute sind user limits der typ hat
uns schon oft mit user limits user limits ich bin mir nur nicht ganz sicher
etc limits und die wohl liegt die jule mit secure ja genau
dann limits wahrscheinlich
ich wusste es leute ich wusste es der typ hat uns wieder mit limits gebetet
limits null ich wusste es einfach ich mir war so klar ok gehen wir mal von aus ich
hätte jetzt nicht irgendwie den den instinkt gehabt nach limits zu gucken
weil er weil er uns das letzte mal schon öfters mit limits gebetet hat wie
hätte man es denn raus bekommen können vielleicht vielleicht durch logs oder
so irgendwie wo steht denn so was drin normalerweise
fail at step spawning ne moment das ist was anderes
ne das ist was anderes
anderes das interessiert nicht or vielleicht weiterhin wie hätte man das
was steht da drin wie hätte man das raus bekommen können
gescheit
wirklich ja ne also ich habe jetzt gleich an limits
gedacht weil warum sollte das not available sein dass das schreit nach
limits und der typ hat uns schon öfters mit limits gebetet zumal es halt so auch
nicht funktioniert und dementsprechend legt das liegt das irgendwie nahe wir
gucken uns wir gucken uns gleich die musterlösung an leute wir müssen uns
auch noch die musterlösung von dem davor angucken
wir haben uns die musterlösung gar nicht angeguckt von dem server web server
hack ding ok also ich muss mal kurz licht anmachen
selbstverständlich über meine heim automatisierung arbeitszimmer deck in
beleuchtung ohne aufzustehen ohne stream zu unterbrechen
ok also limits etc security limits ja fast mit punk konf limits 10.000 beste
sudo zu minus kleint hey wir können uns einloggen
ogu und lasst mich raten jetzt geht das auch easy fertig
fette stunde haben wir gebraucht i sie also check my solution ja korrekt easy
clap easy wir schalten den server noch aus wir wollen da nicht unnötig
und ich unnötig aws zeug verbraten wie ging das letzte jetzt so schnell limits
etc limits etc unlimit etc secure limits so rum eine güde limits auf 10.000
gesetzt und dann ging es der hat uns schlicht und ergreifend nicht erlaubt
prozesse zu spawnen weil er uns hart zu beten möchte der set server admin
ersteller ok gucken wir uns mal die musterlösung dazu an
musterlösung ist
ne das haben wir nicht gemacht wir haben die datei einfach als root gelöscht
running test again permission denied ja das haben wir auch rausgekriegt
etc ssh haben wir auch nachgeguckt set konf haben wir nicht gelöscht
habe ich leer gemacht kommt aus gleiche raus ssh restarted haben wir dann auch
gemacht permissions habe ich ein bisschen verkackt aber dann bin ich drauf
gekommen
das haben wir anders gemacht das haben wir hardcoded auf ein datum gesetzt
minus eins heißt es läuft nie ab das wäre das hier wäre die schönere
lösung gewesen als meins auf jeden fall exe limit ja das habe ich auch
ach so wir hätten einfach die zeile löschen können ja das wäre schlauer
gewesen da ist seine lösung auch besser als meine
ich weiß ich habe jetzt nicht mehr im kopf wer auf werden auf twitter ihm
geschrieben vorhin snap und wie heißt das genau snaps strom gone ich glaube das
ist verkehrt du kannst ihn ja auch mal fragen ob er wusste das wobei ich weiß
nicht ob du letzten film dabei warst wo wir das auch gemacht haben kannst du
mal fragen ob er wusste dass man bei aufgabenummer welche aufgabe waren das
mit dem kett welche aufgabe war das mit dem ch mod wo
ch mod selbst nicht ausführbar war war das das nie weißt du noch jemand wtf das
war das war das ob er weiß ob er weiß dass man wtf it auch mit einem kett auf
ch mod aushebeln kann und umleiten in eine andere datei die exe
kütungrechte hat das hat nämlich letztens im stream einige leute überrascht
dass das funktioniert normalerweise ist das auch sehr eine sehr obskure lösung
des problems schaut der neue chef hier zu keine ahnung wahrscheinlich eher nicht
warum ja setzke 2 2 setzkes haben wir schon ein setzke ist noch left
warum kriege ich eigentlich bei arch mit die drei kein einheitliches die mit dem
feier von schippmann amituna aus aber weiß ich nicht warum du das nicht
hinkriegst elix appearance theme setzen und fertig
layer 8 wahrscheinlich layer 8 ist immer nett ausgedrückt ich mein wirklich
hundertprozentig einheitlich ist es bei mir auch nicht guck mal browser und so
passt ganz ok ist aber andere farbe wie es andere farbe im terminal ist
bisschen andere farbe wie rofi zu hundertprozentig einheitlich ist es auch
nicht das einzige ist bei mir einheitlich das einzige was bei mir einheitlich ist
dass es in dark sieben ist überall
du musst elix appearance für gtk 3 nehmen als normale elix appearance ansonsten
weiß ich auch nicht warum es nicht geht i don't know so leute letztes server
challenge was haben wir denn hier hong kong can write data into database dann
soll hong kong soll es einfach lassen ist nicht so schlimm also aufgabe ist
folgendes scenario daten können nicht in die datenbank geschrieben werden stufe
schwer typ reparieren beschreibung ähnlich wie das manhattan scenario aber
schwieriger war das manhattan scenario das mit mit wordpress
ach moment kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern was manhattan war doch
manhattan war das mit den log files mit den log files und postgres data
ok also ähnlich wie das manhattan scene aber schwieriger ihr ziel ist es eine
zeile in eine bestehende postgres datenbank einzufügen einfügen zu können
das problem ist nicht spezifisch für postgres und sie brauchen keine details
darüber zu wissen obwohl es hilfreich sein könnte
information zu postgres
hast du schon mal ctf gespielt ja aber nie wirklich intensiv und auch nie
wirklich großartig ja ein bisschen ein bisschen rumgeklick auf irgendwelchen
challenge seiten aber als ich habe das weder competitive gemacht noch im team
noch was anderes in der richtung information zu postgres es handelt sich
um einen dienst der an einem port lauscht und auf die festplatte in ein
datenverzeichnis schreibt dessen ort im parameter data directory der
konfigurations datei etc postgres ql 14 main postgres ql konf definiert ist
nice verzeichnis in unserem fall wird postgres von system d als eine unit mit
dem namen postgres ql verwaltet so der test ist folgender sudo minus u
postgres psql insert into persons name value datenbank schritt da habe ich
überhaupt kein bock drauf aber das ist die letzte aufgabe die machen wir jetzt
hongkong
da bin ich ja mal gespannt danach ist es durch wenn es wenn es nach mir geht
gibt es noch 30 andere scenarios weil das macht bock ich glaube der konter
ist ganz interessant und man hat was zu tun
hattest du die 15 schon ist die 15 kuban etas boah da habe ich keinen bock
drauf auf kuban etas stellt das machen vielleicht auch noch aber nicht heute
das vielleicht das sehen wir uns mal als bonus auf die kuban etas aufgabe wenn ich
wenn ich irgendwann irgendwann mal bock auf kuban etas stellt stellt die backen
habe
hier so auf geht's max gratis am arbeiten so könnte man es auch sehen
oh home not set das geht ja schon gut los
ja kuban etas habe ich ja kann man so nennen aber kuban etas ist abfang
ab eine kleine ctf trainings plattform gebaut falls du bock auf rätseln hast
aus welchem bereich also was zum beispiel was haben wir so eine beispiel
aufgabe aber wir müssen die zeit starten 20 minuten der timer ist echt praktisch
oder
das wäre eigentlich richtig feifett idee man macht so eine challenge plattform
und in wirklichkeit löst man echte probleme
du kannst du kannst gerne mal den link posten ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob
das das so mein fachgebiet ist aber post du kannst ruhig den link posten
was ist ctf steht tatsächlich auch für capture the flag geht es hauptsächlich
darum also meistens ist es im security bereich wir müssen übrigens anfangen
meistens ist es irgendwas aus dem security bereich wo wo es eben gilt
verschiedene services zu knacken die manipuliert sind auch eine gewisse art
und weise ja also wo irgendjemand sich überlegt hat ok das könnte ein schönes
rätsel sein so keine ahnung simples beispiel wäre du musst du musst eine
datei mit dem hex editor aufmachen und dann siehst du irgendwas und anhand dessen
was du da gesehen hast kannst du die datei entschlüsseln oder so aber
meistens ein bisschen komplizierter also dass das was wir vorhin gemacht haben
mit hackweb server hier als als challenge das war tatsächlich ziemlich
ziemlich nah an so einer so einer security ctf dran
vom namen her erinnert mich das ein bisschen an mr robot kann das sein
ein bisschen was aber ich müsste robot nie mehr geguckt habe als die erste
staffel ok jetzt müssen wir es aber machen weil die zeit läuft ab also was
ist denn was ist ok unsere postgres datenbank geht nicht also system ctl
nemoin sie ist system ctl status postgres nein ql postgres läuft
aber postgres einfach mal aus und gucken ob die noch stoppen geht moment das ist
so das ist komisch doch wir haben postgres schon gemacht aber das war die
einfache variante davon das ist die schwere variante davon die unit startet
überhaupt kein postgres die units startet einfach und stoppt immer exact
start bin true true lull weh das startet überhaupt kein postgres net stand
minus tulpen läuft einen postgres läuft gar kein postgres
guck mal ok dass die unit ist komplett für den arsch die können wir einfach
ignorieren ja die hat überhaupt keine überhaupt keine aussage kraft schau mal
in service fall mal gucken wo das ding liegt es ist system
ne es ist system d system post daleks nicht ok feind name postgres und dann
punkt service service haben wir denn hier ach gucke mal das gibt es mehrfach was
denn da los muss man das et es capen da der hat die bade oder der hat sie
bade der hat die dateien irgendwie komisch komisch benannt das aber egal
ich werde die postgres datenbank von hand starten erst mal post ne pg
warte mal moment moment wohl wohl wohl legten der kram überhaupt wohl legten das alles war log
user share postgres run postgres moment wir können einfach wir können einfach in
das unit file reingucken da steht es doch etc postgres wo steht in der was da
gestartet mit exec user bin pg wie startet man postgres von hand eg einfach so irgendwie
nie oder irgendwo muss doch irgendwo muss doch das executable für postgres rumliegen
war lip postgres vielleicht war lip postgres
irgendwo muss doch ein postgres executable jaja genau genau so was in der richtung aber
ich finde ich finde die datei nicht wo die liegt run postgres ql vielleicht was ist denn das
wo liegt denn der ganze shit man ja bin postgres da ist es doch ja das habe ich gesucht ok user
lip postgres als root geht nicht mag er nicht als welcher als welcher user läuft denn die
datenbank normalerweise lasst mal kurz gucken gibt es einen postgres user postgres gibt ein
postgres user ok so postgres umi
alles klar ich bin postgres probieren das ganze noch mal zu starten postgres das not
know where to find the server configuration file das server configuration file liegt unter
etc postgres ql ne doch 14 postgres ql konf und da gibt es jetzt ein data directory opt
pg data main opt pg dat da ist überhaupt nichts drin das kann keine datenbank sein ok wir
führen das einfach mal aus minus minus d etc ich meine wenn es von hand ausgeführt wird
dann kann ich auch mit dem service starten postgres post 14 postgres ql konf could not
access server configuration file was hat es hat es die falschen rechte 8d ist ein directory
die habe ich die meinen ich habe die falschen optionen kann das sein wir machen es mal anders
oder oder sind keine berechtigung minus minus konfig file gleich muss man dann wahrscheinlich
machen ok skipping missing configuration ok alles richtig alles richtig plus data directory
opt pg main does not exist mk dir opt pg data main fuck geht immer neu ich data directory
has wrong owner alter see her own postgres postgres opt pg data minus er ok weiter permission
c h mod ok 750 minus er opt pg data jetzt aber weil opt pg data pg version is missing
ich sag doch das ist keine gültige datenbank da liegt nix drin das gibt es nicht ok pg version
das wollte ich auch mal ich wollte gerade ja das ist tatsächlich das was ich aufwarte
ich wollte mit fein mal gucken ob es dieses pg was das ist wahrscheinlich einfach das
falsche falsche verzeichnis der typische am dauerte beten hier akuma da war lip post
fest 14 main pg version aber dazu bieten hat er uns hat er uns wieder tschie betet wenn
da jetzt auch die rechte nicht stimmen dann dreh ich wird dreh ich durch die rechte stimmen
ok gut also wim etc postgres 14 postgres ql konf data directory ich sehe meinen kursor
nicht da dieser data directory zack ok moment das ist sogar das das ist sogar das default
ja da hätte ich das hätte ich auch der kann ich einfach aus kommentieren und gut ist ok
und jetzt sudo darkstone wenn du was wissen will sag bescheid ich hab selbst ich kann
aber gerade nichts wirklich erklären weil ich selbst nur try und er haben alter was
er jetzt schon wieder postgres das not know where to find database data muss ich es doch
wieder rein machen es startet es läuft aber irgendwelche komischen fehler noch
statistics files wer braucht denn sowas ok gucken wir mal gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert
nachdem ich das von hand gestartet habe muss ich aufpassen ich mache mal ein zweites terminal
auf ich hoffe man man man ks fast fast fast wieder liegt aber nicht genug liegt dass
man damit was anfangen kann wenn man jetzt zweites verzeichnis auf und zwar jetzt mal
so zweites verzeichnis auf und wir führen das hier jetzt mal aus natürlich natürlich
geht es nicht wäre auch zu er wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen warum geht es nicht
wo ist das problem database das not exist man muss jetzt auch eine datenbank von hand
anlegen postgres ich hab doch keine ahnung mensch von postgres create a database stack
overflow create database from command line ok create user create db create db alles klar
su-i postgres create db und wie muss die db heißen dt dt das scheint das scheint funktioniert
zu haben su-u postgres psgl insert relations person das not exist ah muss ich jetzt auch
tabellen da drin anlegen ok sql time leute create table create table oh shit man wie geht
das ok postgres ql create gibt es auch ein create dafür nee ok wir nehmen einfach leute
wir machen das so koa wir nehmen einfach dieses kommando hier wir nehmen dieses kommando und
sagen create passt mal auf jetzt könnt ihr meine krassen sql skills sehen create table
wie muss das heißen persons oder persons ich brauche ein example dafür weil ich muss
auch noch felder und sowas erstellen ja wunderbar create table persons klammer auf klammer zu
name wie macht man ein string ah beispiele kommt mal hier 255 geht das jetzt hey hey es
hat funktioniert jetzt nochmal easy easy easy as fuck easy so mal gucken ob das jetzt auch
stimmt was ich da gemacht habe mal kurz umschieben mal gucken ob das jetzt auch stimmt was ich
gemacht habe check my solution korrekt easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy
easy easy easy easy easy
der Fairness halber
muss ich sagen
diese Lösung
ist so ziemlich
die abartigste die geht
ja
ich hab kein Unit File gemacht
ich hab das Ding von Hand erstellt
wahrscheinlich in einem Verzeichnis wo es überhaupt nichts zu suchen hat
ich hab die Datenbank von Hand angelegt
die es wahrscheinlich
irgendwo gibt
auf dem System
die Lösung ist richtig
reu nicht schlecht
aber ey das ist das zählt nicht
wichtig ist das der Check sagt
die Solution ist korrekt
der Rest ist egal
Power off
wir gucken uns mal die Musterlösung an
Moment
Next Clue
System City darauf bin ich auch
reingefallen
darauf bin ich auch
reingefallen dass es gar keinen
Service gibt für Postgres
sondern das bin true ist
true 0w
ne das
PS hab ich gar nicht gemacht ich hab netZ
geguckt ob der Port auf ist
wir müssen uns übrigens immer noch die Musterlösung
von dem Hacker Zeug angucken
machen wir gleich danach
Try to start Postgres
ne hab ich nicht gemacht
ja das Journal
CTL ne hab ich nicht gemacht
ich hab es direkt gesehen
dass es bin true ist
beziehungsweise der Port war nicht
auf also eigentlich
da find ich meine Sache sogar besser
a log message
say timed out waiting for
but there is no data
timed
ah
da gabs ne ungemountete
Platte
hehehehehe
ey meine Lösung hat
funktioniert da stand nicht
davon dass die Daten vorhanden bleiben sollen
also
die Daten sind halt weg aber das Hit
Da gab es eine ungemountetes Device, was man hätte mau- ach sooo, ok.
Ja ok, man soll die Disk mounten, alles klar, da hätte ich jetzt nicht dran gedacht.
Die Aufgabe hat Existing Database, achja, ne die hat ja Existed, die Database hat Existed
in dem Verzeichnis, die war da, da war nix drin angelegt, aber die, wobei, ja nicht ganz,
es war was da, was aussieht wie ne Postflussdatenbank, ok und danach, does not work, inactive unit,
ok leute, die offizielle Lösung ist komplett anders als meine, jetzt redet es nicht schön,
ich hab auf Check Solution geklickt, meine Solution war ok, das heißt alles richtig
gemacht, System D, Controls, Mounts, ok, achja, ok, jetzt soll man gucken, dass der Kram
richtig eingebunden wird, jetzt müssen sie in Hongkong halt die Datenbank neu machen,
das ist nicht mein Problem, no space left on device, alter wir haben ja die Hälfte
von der Aufgabe umgangen, damit, wir haben die Hälfte der Aufgabe umgangen, wir haben
die Datenbank von Hand gestartet und neu angelegt, jetzt müssten wir noch die Disc, hätten wir
noch die Disc resizen müssen, ja was juckt mich, was die in Hongkong jetzt für ein Problem
haben, ok, jetzt muss man wieder Backup Files löschen, also ganz ehrlich, wenn in dem Ticket
drin gestanden hätte, der Test Case ist das hier und der Test Case wäre erfolgreich,
dann hätte ich das wieder wie der China-Chinesen-Inda bei Fiverr gemacht, hat gesagt, passt, kein
Problem, Test ist erfolgreich, Rest interessiert mich nicht, gelernt auf Arbeit oder wegen
Video, von was sprichst du jetzt, was meinst du, ach, ich wollte mir die Seite speichern
von vorhin, ist die noch in der History, die CTF-Seite von dem, der im Chat war, der da
irgendwelche Mr.
Robot Geschichten benannt war, ach hier, ich hab's gefunden, speicher ich mir mal,
vielleicht, vielleicht ist das auch was Praktisches, was man machen könnte im Stream, ok, also
was ist als nächstes, Delete, das ist die Solution, ok, unsere Solution ist komplett
anders als seine, seine Solution ist definitiv die bessere als meine, bei mir ist die Datenbank
halt einfach jetzt resettet worden, aber sie lief danach und die hat auch Daten angenommen,
also ich hab's gelöst, aber nicht schön, das hier ist die bessere Variante, aber ich
hätte im Leben nicht dran gedacht, zu checken, ob da noch eine Disk eingehängt werden kann
oder so, na gut, dann lass uns doch mal schnell die offizielle Lösung von Hack a Web Server
angucken, dann müssen wir jetzt wieder warten, bis das aufgebaut ist, aber dann haben wir
alle, bis auf die Kubernetes-Aufgabe durch, die Kubernetes-Aufgabe hebe ich mir mal auf,
da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, keinen Bock auf Kubernetes-Stells jetzt, wir schauen uns
mal die Musterlösung hierzu an, der Chat hat's ja schon wieder verpetzt, müsst ihr euch
mal vorstellen, für alle, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, wir haben festgestellt, die Aufgabe
ist ein bisschen kaputt, hier steht drinnen, dass man keine Hutrechte auf dem Server hat,
das erste, was ich gemacht hab, ist sudo-i, das ist Nummer 18 jetzt, sudo-i, wir haben
doch Admin-Rechte, und dann ist jemand aus dem Stream auf Twitter gegangen und hat dem
Ersteller dieser Services gepostet, es ist kaputt und jetzt fixt er das, aber es soll
mir recht sein, weil die Aufgabe ist ja auch auf jeden Fall dafür gemacht, nicht als Route,
nicht als Route gelöst zu werden, wir haben's ausnutzen können, dem Rest ist mir egal,
wir haben's uns ja auch angeguckt, wie es geht, ohne Route-Rechte haben wir ja auch gemacht,
ok, also was ist die offizielle Lösung, we can see one file, ls war www.html, ja, das
haben wir gemacht, apache is asking for credentials, das ist uns auch aufgefallen dann, we can
see, ach das konnte man sich angucken, das wusste ich nicht, ok, aber wir haben die
Datei gefunden, ht-passmede, carlos, bitconnect, vom New York City, das haben wir gemacht,
wir haben das Passwort von carlos rausbekommen, genau charlotte war das Passwort, dann hat
er sich die Datei gespeichert, dann hat er festgestellt, das ist ein zip-archiv, das
habe ich auch gemerkt, ja, nur dass ich per Route in das Verzeichnis gegangen bin und
mir die Datei hinkopiert habe, ich hab quasi Schritte 1 bis 4 übersprungen, weil ich unerwartet
Route-Rechte hatte auf der Kiste, radiosignale kann ich gleich was zu sagen, das haben wir
gemacht, unzip, ging nicht, danach haben wir es ungefähr so, wie er hier auch gemacht,
das Passwort von dem zip-File zu knacken, dann haben wir das Passwort vom Secrets-File
bekommen und konnten es unzipen, ja, genau, fertig, so haben wir das auch gemacht, nur
mit dem Unterschied, dass wir Schritt 1 bis 4 übersprungen haben, weil wir Route-Rechte
hatten, allerdings muss man sagen, wir haben es dann nachher auch noch mal gemacht, ohne
Route-Rechte, nice, also es ist ein mega-nices Projekt, ich glaube, ich werde dem Betreiber
auf Twitter nachher auch noch mal schreiben, dass ich das äußerst enjoyed habe, das zu
machen und ich mich freuen würde, wenn es mehr Challenges gibt und ich hoffe, ihm hat
ein bisschen Exposure auf Twitch gefallen, alles klar, so, radiosignale, was gibt's,
ich habe ein lokales Docker-Image mit einer WordPress-Seite, wie bekomme ich es hin, dass
ich die Seite lokal mit HTTPS WordPress.test aufrufen kann, das müsste, nee, nee, nee,
das funktioniert nicht mit Let's Encrypt, weil dir WordPress, es sei denn, dir gehört
die Domain WordPress.test, gehörte die Domain WordPress.test, bist du Owner dieser Domain,
also ich vermute mal nicht, würde mich, wenn er sagt ja, würde mich das wundern, aber
weiß er nicht, nee, das geht nicht nur darum, wenn du es mit Let's Encrypt machen willst,
musst du Owner, Besitzer der Domain sein, also mit Let's Encrypt geht es nicht, wenn
du die Domain nicht besitzt, du kannst dir ein Self-Signed-Zertifikat machen mit Open
SSL, frag mich aus dem Kopf nicht, Open SSL, nee, es muss nicht public sein, public muss
es bei Let's Encrypt nur für HTTP-Challenge sein, mit DNS kann es auch private sein,
ist kein Ding, geht auch, also gehen wir jetzt mal, spielen wir mal zwei Szenarien durch,
das erste Szenario ist, dir gehört die Domain, aber du möchtest diesen Service nur intern
betreiben, dann kannst du es mit Let's Encrypt machen, nämlich Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge
kannst du machen, zum Beispiel über Cloudflare oder Hetzner oder Namecheap oder was auch
immer, es ist egal, irgendein Anbieter, der eine DNS-API hat, in den Augen, dann kannst
du Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge machen, das funktioniert folgendermaßen, Let's Encrypt,
also die ganz ganz ganz Kurzfassung, du brauchst dafür einen Webserver, der es eingebaut hat
oder du benutzt sowas wie Certbot und sagst Certbot mit DNS-Challenge, das funktioniert
folgendermaßen, Certbot connectet sich zu Let's Encrypt, Let's Encrypt gibt dir ein
geheimes Secret und dieses geheimes Secret musst du als Beweis, dass du der Besitzer
der Domain bist, musst du dieses geheimes Secret, was ja quasi nur du und Let's Encrypt
kennen, wobei ich noch nicht mal sicher bin, ob es sogar Let's Encrypt kennt oder ob das
irgendwas Asynchrones ist, keine Ahnung, aus dem Kopf, genau, muss ich nachgucken, zumindest
gibt dir Certbot ein geheimes Secret, das musst du als TXT-Rekord in deinem DNS hinterlegen
und dadurch, dass du dieses geheimes Secret in deinem DNS hinterlegt hast, bist du ja
automatisch der Besitzer, weil sonst hättest du ja keinen Zugriff auf den DNS-Server für
diese Domain, das geht aber nur, wenn du wirklich Besitzer der Domain bist. Der zweite
Fall ist, dir gehört die Domain nicht und du willst es, du willst so tun, als gehört
sie dir lokal, dann musst du mit OpenSSL dir ein Self-Sign-Zertifikat ausstellen, das wird
aber auf jeden Fall Warnungen geben, es sei denn, du importierst, du kannst dem auch Trusten
oder du importierst die CA, mit der du das lokale Zertifikat ausgestellt hast, als Trusted
in deinen Browser oder bei Windows in den Trusted Store oder sowas, in diesen Trusted
Store oder unter Linux kopierst du es in den Trusted Third Store, das würde auch funktionieren,
aber lokal, wenn dir die Domain nicht gehört, musst du Self-Sign-Zertifikat benutzen, so
sieht es aus. Ja, das funktioniert, genau das ist das, was ich gerade versucht habe
zu umschreiben. Besser wäre es aber, du machst mit Let's Encrypt, weil dann ist es automatisch
gültig und mit einer Domain, die du besitzt, also das ist wirklich die aller einfachste
Variante, kauf dir eine billige Domain, 5€ im Jahr und machst damit, dann hast du immer
gültige Zertifikate, dem automatisch jeder Browser Trusted, weil sie von Let's Encrypt
kommen und du kannst rein lokale Services betreiben mit der DNS-Challenge. Also überhaupt
gar kein Ding. Ja, geheim insofern, dass es halt nur dir mitgeteilt wird und wenn du es
dann hinterlegt hast, ist ja auch egal. MK-CERT, Simple Zero Config Tool to Make Locally Trusted
Development Certificate. Kannte ich noch nicht, ist das Written in Go, selbstverständlich
Written in Go, das könnte man nur noch toppen durch, Leute, durch was könnte man das toppen?
Es gibt eigentlich nur eine Möglichkeit, wie man es noch toppen kann, sage ich da
nur zu. Dann ist es nämlich auch automatisch Blazingly Fast, weil wir wissen ja alles,
alles was in Rust programmiert ist, ist automatisch Blazingly Fast. Krabbe, genau, in Crap programmiert.
Heute bin ich besonders lustig, aber es ist ja auch Fasching, da sind die Leute alle lustig.
In Brainfuck. Leute, ich sollte mir wirklich mal, ich sollte mir wirklich mal eine Rust-Krabbe
transparent als, eine Rust-Krabbe transparent, mit transparent im Hintergrund, please, jawoll,
sehr gut. Jawoll, jetzt haben wir auch Blazingly Fast Written in Rust, ganz essentiell, dass
wir das Rust Maskottchen hier noch drin haben. Okay, gibt es, okay, wir müssen jetzt mal
suchen, eine sage ich mal. Rust-Blazingly-Fast-Meme. Oldest Language. Ähm. Ich weiß nicht,
ich traue mich nicht die Memes zu öffnen. Ich habe da meine Bedenken, dass gleich irgendwelches
grenzwertige Zeug kommt, wenn ich da auf Bilder klicke. Ich glaube, das ist keine so gute
Idee. Was ist das? Awesome Blazingly Fast. Satire Awesome List Blazingly Fast. Der macht
auch neuerdings viel Rust auf YouTube, habe ich gesehen. Moin Klugscheiser. Bester Name.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern gleich. Ich wollte noch hier an jemanden, äh, was
Motion Dev, was ist die Question? Bekomme bei Netboot immer Connection Timeout, wenn
ich ein Linux über das Netzwerk installieren möchte. Jemand eine Ahnung warum? Hast du
PXEboot bei dir lokal am Laufen? Das kommt sich mit dem Imagebooten in die Quere. Also
wenn du das Imagebooten willst, dann hat das manchmal Probleme mit PXEboot, falls du lokales
PXEboot hast. Hast du lokales PXEboot? Ansonsten Nope. Probier mal UEFI zu booten, ansonsten
fällt mir da nicht viel ein. Also da muss ich ehrlich sagen, also Netboot funktioniert
in der Regel recht gut. Nee, habe ich keine weitere Ahnung, was das sein könnte. Was
gibt es heute zum Essen wahrscheinlich? Prostbrot oder sowas, weiß ich noch nicht genau. Ja,
es geht ja nicht um Docker Container, es geht ja um normale Kisten oder? Also um VMs wahrscheinlich.
Nee, Firewall kann eigentlich auch nicht sein, wenn die normalen Rechner aus dem gleichen
Netz per DACP eine IP kriegen und ins Internet kommen, sollte Netboot das auch hinbekommen.
Aber bei normalen Rechtern geht das, ja. Du kannst auch in die Host Datei schreiben, wenn
du Self-Sign Sachen hast. Und bei Let's Encrypt musst du nichts umbiegen. Achso, das meinst
du, ja doch, da hast du recht, das musst du umbiegen. Du musst intern natürlich die Namen
auflösen und extern nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Aber nicht wirklich umbiegen, du musst einfach
deinen internen Server, deinem internen DNS-Server sagen, hier, ich bin, ich liefere dafür jetzt
was aus. Also ein DNS-Mask oder irgendeinen statischen Eintrag auf deinem Router oder
so, das ist halt, das muss dann natürlich lokal aufgelöst werden können. Weil Zertifikate
gehen ja nach dem Namen, die drinnen stehen und nicht nach der IP, also was auch logisch
ist, dass sie mehrere Services haben auf einer IP.
Alles klar Leute, dann sind wir für heute durch Zetkes Server Happy gemacht. Übrigens,
ich habe mir schon das überlegt, was wir im nächsten Stream machen. Wir machen den
nächsten Stream Pimp my NeoWim. Da habe ich irgendwie Bock drauf. Ich habe nicht von NeoWim
hauptsächlich als Editor zu verwenden. Ich benutze Wim als Commandline Editor regelmäßig,
aber für größere Sachen nehme ich entweder die Jetbrain-IDEs oder halt Wishlist Studio
Code. Ich habe nicht wirklich vor Wishlist Studio Code irgendwie durch NeoWim oder sowas
abzulösen, aber ich will mal gucken, was es da also gibt. Schadet ja nichts, wenn man
ein bisschen Durchblick hat. Mit Lua, klar, natürlich mit Lua. Hast du NeoWim installiert,
kannst du den kurz vorstellen? Installiert habe ich ihn glaube ich. Nee, ich glaube,
ich habe ihn noch nicht mal installiert. Das ist exakt 1 zu 1 Replacement für Wim an der
Stelle, nur dass es mehr, deutlich mehr kann mittlerweile. Also wenn du Wim kannst, kannst
du auch NeoWim bedienen. Die Jacken sind wieder am Start. Richtig funny alle. Wo ist
jetzt DNS Monitoring? Das müssen wir tatsächlich auch noch fertig machen. Nicht DNS, du meinst
nicht DNS Monitoring, du meinst Domain Monitoring, Expire und sowas. Ja, das müssen wir auch
noch fertig machen. Dann gibt es theoretisch den Label-Champ, der muss ja auch noch irgendwann
mal fertig gemacht werden, aber das schreibe ich erst gar nicht rein, da kommt es wahrscheinlich
eh nicht dazu. Ich kenne mich ja, sei denn ich habe wieder Bock auf das Projekt. Der
Fiat-Champ, da habe ich heute Morgen nachgeguckt. Es gab ein Issue, dass Alpha-Romeo-Support,
ob man das einbauen kann. Das geht allerdings nicht, weil der falsche Uconnect-Service benutzt
wird. Dann geht sein Auto nicht. Dann geht sein Auto nicht, wenn es nicht über die Seite
funktioniert. F. Okay Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern, wir sehen uns bis dann, machts
gut. See you. Dann brauche ich noch mehr Prime-Subs, wenn ich mir ein neues Auto kaufen soll,
nur um ein Issue zu fixen. Da brauchen wir viele Primers jetzt. Richtig viele Primers,
sonst wird das nichts mit dem Auto kaufen, nur für ein Issue. Suki, danke schön für
den Primers, aber ich fürchte, das reicht nicht für ein neues Auto. Aber trotzdem,
3 Subscription. Ferrari-Champ. Ich meine, der Fiat-Champ kann immerhin. Der kann Fiat,
Pluto-Kicks, danke für den Sub. Ich meine, der kann immerhin. Fiat, Jeep, Ram und eventuell
Dodge und Alfa Romeo, wenn es den richtigen Ap-Service benutzt. Er benutzt halt den falschen.
Alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns bis dann, machts gut. Danke nochmal für die Subs Leute.
Auch an alle anderen, die heute subscribt haben, die ich vielleicht übersehen habe.
Wir sehen uns bis dann, see you.